in Germany I've Anka Trump told the
crowd that her father is a champion of
supporting families and she got booed
yeah
Ivanka said she was surprised she's
always been told to open with a joke and
a real family guy anyone would get that
one it's obviously a joke yeah seriously
Ivanka Trump was booed in Germany that's
the big story apparently she told the
people of Berlin why would you get rid
of a perfectly good wall you had one you
got rid of it
you had it you could have given it to us
I could have used it speaking of the
wall I don't know if you heard about
this top Republicans are now saying that
trumps border wall doesn't mean an
actual wall but a metaphor now which
makes sense because during the campaign
all those Trump supporters were shouting
build-up metaphor pillow Tom metaphor
metaphor build it it's gonna be a
beautiful metaphor yeah when my parents
used to promise to take us to Disney
World they would say later oh we just
met a metaphor yeah
the backyard with the hose the US State
Department has hired a female anchor
away from Fox News yeah however the
State Department describes it as more of
a rescue mission
fine that did get enough that's fine you
gave me what I needed to go forward
night thank you
hey get this no now you know
now you went too far
you over-tipped me Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia I didn't do a joke yet this guy
I'm like Saudi Arab and he's like how
does he do it like there could be such a
place
Saudi Arabia has been named to the
United Nations Commission on women's
rights yeah in a related story Ireland
has been named to the UN Commission on
sobriety and tanning so we're in good
shape
Japan always coming up with new devices
a company in Japan has created a device
to help parent shut down their child's
smartphone if they use it too much you
can set it down cool yes
it's meant for children ages 6 to 12 or
the President of the United States
[Applause]
El Chapo in the news el chapo has been
complaining about conditions in his
Manhattan jail cell
yeah parently because it's Manhattan el
chapo is being charged at $12 toll every
time he uses his own tunnel you see
please two kind on that one I almost
didn't do that one a try it come on yeah
just do it you laughed at it so much
yourself today yeah exactly they felt
sorry for me and then they laughed yeah
a Nature Preserve in Kenya has set up a
tinder account to find a mate for its
male white rhino yeah
and today the Rhino revealed it would
prefer to be on Grindr actually
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm swiping and making the horn at the
same time and I'm the mine who tells you
what he's doing
you